good morning everybody I'm Melissa smait
the executive director of the Arts
Initiative and Miller theater at
Columbia University and it is my very
great pleasure to welcome you this
morning to this extraordinary
conversation with Professor Elaine
Sisson and the incomparable Valeri
Gergiev
this is the very first collaboration of
the world leaders forum the core
curriculum and Miller theatre so I
certainly hope it will not be the last
we would also like to extend our special
thanks to Columbia Center for the core
curriculum and the music humanities core
st. Petersburg State University the
knowledge is power program charter
schools and especially
PricewaterhouseCoopers for their support
of this event as you as you may know we
are being joined live today by a group
of students at st. Petersburg State
University in Russia who will also be
participating in the question and answer
session that will follow today's talk
it's incredibly exciting to have a truly
global audience for this world leaders
forum where they are I've been asked to
introduce today's speakers to you as
general director and artistic director
of the mariyinsky theater in st.
Petersburg Russia Valeri Gergiev leads
the Mariinsky Opera Ballet and orchestra
he is also principal conductor of the
London Symphony Orchestra born in Moscow
maestro Gergiev studied conducting at
the Leningrad Conservatory and at the
age of 23 won Berlin's prestigious
herbert von carry on music prize he made
his care of opera debut in 1978 with
Prokofiev's warrant peace and was named
artistic director of the opera company
in 1988 at the age of 35 in 1996 the
Russian government gave him complete
control over the orchestra opera and
ballet over the past 15 years he has
significantly expanded the theaters
repertoire demonstrating a passionate
commitment to contemporary composers and
choreographers as well as leading
landmark
of such cornerstones of the repertoire
as vogner's Ring cycle maestro Gergiev
just maybe to borrow a much more in
phrase the hardest-working man in show
business
he's the commanding presence in New
York's cultural landscape last season he
conducted the complete Mahler's
symphonies with two of the world's
leading orchestras and two of New York's
most important concert halls leaving the
mariyinsky Orchestra at Carnegie Hall
and the London Symphony Orchestra at
Avery Fisher he conducted a brand new
production of Missouri's monumental
opera Boris Godunov at the Metropolitan
Opera in April he led the New York
Philharmonic and a series of
performances as part of a special
festival called the Russian Stravinsky
including beloved masterpieces such as
the Firebird the Rite of Spring symphony
of Psalms and the Opera Oedipus Rex and
over the summer he was at the podium for
the Mariinsky ballets return to Lincoln
Center leading the United States
premiere performances of two new ballets
and that's just one season and just in
New York the maestro schedule takes him
around the world for guests conducting
engagements with among others the Royal
Opera House Covent Garden Teatro alla
Scala and the Vienna Philharmonic over
the course of his career he has worked
with nearly all of the world's major
international orchestras and opera
companies earlier this week he returned
to New York to open Carnegie Hall's
120th anniversary season with the
mariyinsky Orchestra embarking on a
survey of Tchaikovsky symphonies
reviewing the first concert the New York
Times likened the Meister's unique
ability to highlight the color and
character of each instrument to seeing
rimsky-korsakov's book on orchestration
come to life onstage
today's conversation will be moderated
by Elaine suspend the Ann Parsons bender
professor of music at Columbia
University miss this mandir columbia
faculty in 1982 and served as chair of
the music department from 1999 to 2005
the former president of the American
music illogical Society she specializes
in music of the 18th and 19th centuries
and has written extensively on the music
of Beethoven Hyden Mozart and Brahms
she studied piano at Juilliard and
Cornell and
her doctorate in music history at
Princeton she has taught at the
University of Michigan and Harvard
University and has been awarded grants
from the National Endowment for the
Humanities and the American Council of
learned societies Columbia has honored
her with its great teacher award and the
award for distinguished service to the
core curriculum so we are in for quite a
treat
professor sis Minh will lead the first
part of the discussion but there will be
an opportunity for questions later in
the program from both the audience here
in this room and from our friends in st.
Petersburg I would encourage you all to
be bold and ask whatever questions you
may have whether they are about
Tchaikovsky and the grand tradition of
Russian music are simply questions about
the day-to-day challenges of working
with superstar classical music soloists
this is your chance to get an inside
perspective on classical music and I
really encourage you to take advantage
of it I would also like to extend an
invitation for all of you in New York to
join us for the post-talk reception at
Faculty House where you will have an
opportunity to meet this world-famous
musician thank you and enjoy
we'd like to begin with a video clip of
your recent work new release from the
Mariinsky label
what better way to start than with the
Tchaikovsky fourth you're here to open
the Carnegie Hall season with with
performances of Tchaikovsky's include
symphonies all six of them and I guess
we've already heard part of the answer
to the question what do these pieces
still have to say to us today well a
great symphonies and Tchaikovsky is
popular for certain reasons people come
and enjoy his music for last under 20
years at least here in America eleven
maybe hundred forty hundred fifty years
in Russia and they want more of it every
day Nahum the performance of gana
concerto a violin concerto or Swan Lake
or Nutcracker or the symphonies and so
on I can continue forever me again Queen
of Spades it's not only a big happening
it's also invitation for tomorrow and I
think music is so full of beauty and
fantastic melodies sometimes people say
what is Russia's soul there is no answer
to it but you come closer to answer if
you just experience yet another time
what is Tchaikovsky Symphony telling you
what is instrumental concerto just two
days ago
yo-yo ma played local corporations not
them not a huge composition but what a
composition
it only takes 17 minutes or 18 minutes
but then you feel it's a whole world and
you were told a fantastic tale and this
is what jakosky could do with ballet
with opera with symphony with many many
different compositions he was always
here and I think in Carnegie Hall
tradition there are many many great
names but somehow it is not only very
pleasing to think that it started with
Tchaikovsky and even here he was amongst
very very best because there was a
reason why he was invited here to open
Carnegie Hall I think he just fantastic
musician and he takes say ballet is a
genre takes it here and this is way he
lives it and it's what he did basically
everywhere really the first great
composer to write ballet music when you
conduct Tchaikovsky in Russia how is the
response different from what you've
experienced here conduct Tchaikovsky
let's say there is always a response I
don't think his music has this ability
to live a lot of people untouched or
better to say it's unable to do so his
music has direct and very honest way and
then responses coming back and I suppose
normally it's very emotional
overwhelming and it's just very honest
when you hear the dance movements in
Tchaikovsky symphonies it sounds like
his ballet music what is the difference
for you when you're conducting
Tchaikovsky for the ballet said for the
Kirov ballet or for the Symphony
Orchestra I don't see big difference
between conducting ballets on stage or
conducting just Orchestra you focus on
music the best ballet performances
normally are associated with a very high
level of music making we know that they
have fantastic dancers and sometimes
conductor can only follow them but even
better scenario is when there is a
fantastic dancer on stage with the
beauty of music coming from the
orchestra and Tchaikovsky had incredible
quality he was a big symphonic composer
so his intellectual capacity was
enormous
his melodic gifts were equal to those
free for most famous melodies of all
time Mozart or Puccini Verdi Rossini but
then comes Tchaikovsky clearly he will
be always in a big free or big for a big
fight of all times because the whole
world loves this those melodies but then
comes his incredible theatricality
that's why his ballet music is so
memorable
so danceable and then comes his
symphonic power
so even Nutcracker we call this show
cool chick in my country maybe most
popular than at all times easy to say
there is a competition from Swan Lake
but here you have this fantastic very
memorable music so it's very in a way
very simple it just goes straight to her
heart but there is a huge quality of
organization of this composition and his
symphonic writing is so impeccable so he
combines what we always try in our lives
pleasure and seriousness to be very
beautiful but also to be organized to be
very fresh but also very wise as he
somehow has it all
and in the fourth symphony that we just
heard it's also a powerfully dramatic
moment well you you can't escape it if
you live in Russia it's always a little
bit dramatic so
you've also been a champion of 20th
century Russian works and have brought
the premieres of Prokofiev's war and
peace and the gambler to the
Metropolitan Opera and I heard you state
that you thought people who were going
to spend the rest of their lives just
going to performances of Otello and La
Traviata really need something else to
hear would you like to see those works
become repertory staples at the Met well
first of all I conducted to tailor and
traviata' at the Met - so you caught me
with a repertoire here I think Traviata
and hotel fantastic operas but I think
our lives are a little bit poor if we
only think that there are three operas
or maximum five operas actually there
are hundred at least worth our attention
and my work all my life is focused on
making it easier for millions of people
to understand why fiery angel should be
performed so I recorded this we made a
video of this production The Gambler
Semyon Cutco or patrolling a monastery
and of course lava free oranges yes
Warren piece gigantic or appease I still
remember how then it was practically her
big debut on the main stage unknown yet
Repco was singing a famous role of
Natasha Rostova
and she looked the role and she sounds
and she acts but the whole production
was a fantastic event here in New York
and just one year before we did it in
Russia the same production it started
there and audiences were thrilled I
remember you couldn't get a ticket here
you couldn't get it to get there because
there is something special about the
soccer so it's not only Traviata which
by the way and sings beautifully
traviata' so she finds it good she finds
it very necessary to sing both I find it
necessary to conduct sterling skip Rock
coffee of Shostakovich and even
contemporary composers living composers
but I go back and contact where do
Tchaikovsky all the time Wagner OPA
Chile all the time
it makes my life much more interesting
so you don't ignore giants like
Prokofiev because it's not Prokofiev who
will suffer we will suffer that's the
answer the gambler is World War one for
coffee F the young hothead International
Warren pieces World War two for coffee F
already under the Soviet thumb is are
there differences you see in those works
that connect to Prokofiev's change
politically naturally you hear opera the
gambler and you think of the styrsky you
also think of totally different scale
Prokofiev envisage himself
for example the gambler everything is
around one person it's fantastic world
around this person incredible story
Dostoyevsky was a master of
characteristics Prokofiev it appears
even being a very young man
twenty-something was a master of this
immediate he captured the most important
and by the way the stairs kiss novel is
not very big but Prokofiev even
shortened it so he just left most
important fabulo know just to make it
work as an opera production and it's
extremely explosive has phenomenal
climax in Rowlett scene you know the
gambling is seen I love this opera I
thought New York City love this opera -
that was my feeling we did it many times
here revival brought even more
interesting thing so that's the best
proof of opera being
truly great some people come to the
first performance more people come to
the second performance because the word
of mouth helps sometimes it's opposite a
lot of people come to the first a big
expectation disappointment and
diminishing and then it goes to nothing
the interest is gone the appreciation is
small and so on in case of both the
gambler and warring piece it made this
enormous crescendo in both cases
worldwide we brought war and peace
production to Madrid to La Scala to
Covent Garden to Tokyo of course Moscow
Petersburg New York it's quite a lot and
then we wanted to do many many more
things with Prokofiev repertoire so we
wanted to stage of relaxing on Cutco
truly great opera truly great opera
I still remember recently few I have
performed in Adam in concept form for
Eddie Morgan national festival
phenomenal reaction from the public just
people jump out of their chairs because
the power of this music act free I
performed in concert is such that people
can't stay no just away from what just
happens away it just takes them so it's
like power of nature this is the first
sign of great composer Verdi had this
power Wagner had this power yes
Prokofiev has this power and Warren
piece is just totally different as I
promised a different scale you want to
have all embracing picture you follow
Tolstoy the book is like this as you all
know and then opera is like this and
then you have to be prepared to spend
four hours or more in opera house you
have to be prepared for the epics even
Napoleon himself will sing for you and
how yeah and it's also very cinematic
so Prokofiev was a great film composer
sometimes skis not mentioned amongst
those film composers for me he was the
best ever if you just look what he did
for Alexander Nevsky or I wonder
terrible very difficult too much we use
it in the sports it's a world record
yeah 70 years ago or more difficult to
beat even today so I think if we talk
about Prokofiev of course I'm very proud
he represents Russian school but we will
play in few days at Carnegie Hall
just three accepts from Romeo Juliet and
again after Tchaikovsky and after
history ballet music they were
Stravinsky there were many great
composers and again maybe Prokofiev
takes the gold because he's Rimmel
Juliet again is a champion on the
twentieth century this score stands very
very high even speaking about Stravinsky
who solve this huge revolution came with
a sucker with petrushka with the
Firebird and knows fantastic but
Prokofiev it's very human in that true
love story in a true tragedy and it's
true drama and it's so beautiful and I
think we are very very happy to be
musicians because that's how we spend
our life today Prokofiev tomorrow Verdi
there's a demo Tchaikovsky it's for me
it's even more important than breakfast
another important figure in the Opera
House is the director and one notable
mishap that occurred during the premiere
of The Gambler was there was a
complicated piece of stage machinery and
a singer fell into the pit it was a
large piece what are the piece I was
warned piece yes the question is do you
have a say in anything having to do with
the direction of an opera what do you
struggle with directors sometimes if
your musical vision I love I love to
work with directors some of them a
problem some of them are friends some of
them are huge
but some of them some of them are just
fantastic game fantastic a victory when
opera comes to a harmony where sets
costumes lights music voices director
and conductor sometimes are important
but when they work together and you feel
that it's the best thing you ever
experienced then most probably you can
say finally so you you wait don't buddy
directors come and go but then comes
real D Big D director and then things
are looking fantastic
so I admire directors but I know that
they're dangerous and is it different
all over the world are there different
kinds of directors and issues in
producing opera in the many places that
you've you've conducted well
thanks got opera leaves and thrives
because there is no crisis in opera
world the opera houses are full
yesterday I was at the end of
performance I just conducted two
symphonies only yesterday when I had to
excuse myself no signing nothing and I
went straight to the Metropolitan Opera
I listened to the last 20 minutes of uh
Nabiullina Dropper of Donizetti and Anna
Netrebko
was singing the role of Anna Bolena it
was gorgeous and the house was not only
full house was full of emotions I think
it was house full of happiness everyone
it seems was felt everyone was happy and
that's what the whole opera story is
about you just make people happy you
make people feel that there is something
in our lives you are ready to sacrifice
many other things because this you
cannot miss I think this is what I
experienced yesterday myself although I
have to say back to Carnegie Hall we
also had totally full house it also also
was difficult to leave this stage
because it seems Chekhov ski also
touched everyone yesterday the Carnegie
Hall so we had at least 7,000 people
also yesterday in one
city in one evening stimulus the two
events and I felt those 7,000 people
were clearly make it known they were
happy that's the power of music but in
the last 20 minutes and Berlin is facing
death and she's she's having a mad scene
and then walks to her execution so the
people may be happy in the Opera House
but how could you describe that kind of
happiness when they're watching this
tormented woman yeah you know when I was
maybe 15 years old even maybe when I was
13 years old I also was in trouble I
couldn't understand don't you say just
kills Carmen she's definitely dead
and then Opera House goes it's true but
I I think the audience really must see
how to netrebko sing her voice to hear
an unamplified voice fill the Opera
House one thing that music humanities
students are always surprised by is that
there was no my king at the Met and it's
a miracle of opera
Anna was killed 20 minutes later we had
a very nice dinner together restaurant
across the road so that's the miracle of
opera let me ask you something about
your career you began a very successful
career as we've heard very young under
communism and you were appointed
director of the netsuke theater in the
1990s and have maintained its position
and I wondered if you could say
something about the differences in your
career as you perceive them over the
last few decades and the role of the
theater in particular also in the life
of st. Petersburg I will say nothing
about my career
because there was no not know such a
thing in my life I didn't understand the
word career before it seems I made some
career so I didn't think very much but I
looked at my colleagues maybe when I was
18:19 for the first time in my life I
went to Leningrad it was called great
city for us it's the most beautiful city
in the world and my colleagues there in
st. Petersburg have a privilege to be
there right now New York is also great I
Love New York but slightly younger
cities so let's younger brother but some
people celebrated 300 years not so long
ago but for me being 18 years old 19
years old it was a total shock to hear
great Orchestra great conductor for the
first time in the Great Hall which is
important to hear great opera and ballet
performances that was my first few
months so my destiny was clear I knew
even then in 1972 that I will never
change course I will go on and become
conductor the question was if I will
learn really how to conduct good or
great Orchestra will have a chance to
conduct truly great Orchestra ever in my
life
the answer was not known to me I felt
being very small but I felt the world
around me was very big that was my
luckiest moment because then I learned
in Leningrad so much from colleagues
from friends from professors but also
from my student colleagues by the way we
we were teachers to each other somehow
because one knew a lot about Mozart
another knew a lot about Tchaikovsky and
I knew a lot about contemporary and then
we all go to conservative music like st.
Petersburg University people go every
day and learn learn learn because it's a
lot to learn for all of us even now and
maybe this is what career finally is
about you learn and learn and then you
suddenly discover oh you had the career
already but how did you learn to conduct
when you can't practice with a piano
with a French horn
you can practice weird how do you
develop the skills with an orchestra how
do you develop your ear to
those remarkable colors that you do I
don't know what to say but maybe when
when you are 18 years old and you see
fantastic Hollywood movie and there is a
beautiful beautiful actress anything oh
what a beautiful woman you know really
beautiful it's the same you listen to
the great orchestrating the great
Orchestra but you never know how to
conduct the sixth then comes today you
are there and conduct very same
Orchestra or same quality offices so
when I heard first-time Leningrad
Philharmonic or Berlin Philharmonic or
Vienna former works there life I had no
idea will ever conduct this orchestras
so I learned then because I learned
something my destiny helped me at some
point I was standing there in front of
uniformly saying good morning and then I
start and I conducted enough of the
morning it was just fifteen sixteen
years ago Leningrad Philharmonic maybe
24 years ago Berlin even 30 years ago I
conducted believe harmonic long before I
conducted Leningrad morning because I
was a winner of Herbert von Karajan
competition so only being 23 24 so my
life is not a typical example of how you
built it slowly it just was nothing and
then suddenly you just started but
nothing means you you build learn learn
learn them people don't know you learn
so much because you do it yourself read
listen think at some point you are ready
or at least you're ready to start that's
how I see conducted we don't have much
time to talk about conductors and most
important figure in a musical world is
composer
so if conductor is happy to be his
friend in a way his slave in a way that
most probably means it's a good
conductor most probably
if conductor things that must have spent
all his life doing something and then
comes conductor and just takes it here
and put it there most Probab it's a bad
conductor most probably
we have to understand this that
prokofyeva tchaikovsky are not sort of
Verdi they were blessed you know
somewhere in the skies it was decided
that there will be ten maybe twenty
truly great musicians of all times we
are privileged to have this opportunity
to do it regularly just spend time with
the music
which means with them it's a wonderful
thought you have been a passionate
advocate of getting young people into
the concert hall getting them really to
experience the sounds that you heard
that galvanized you reason we have
students from the knowledge is power
Academy here today the question I wanted
to ask you about that is what is the
best way to enable people to have that
experience and music humanities we go
out into the concert hall to the
Metropolitan Opera and we have great
spaces but for for young people how can
we how can we do that you can't
guarantee that someone will have the
experience you have but you have to put
them closer to being able to have it
well I didn't know you will start with
the symphony number four of Tchaikovsky
I also did not know a long time ago
before I heard any music you remember
this long play the records longer I
don't know how it happened to me maybe I
was fifteen years old
I just heard a famous recording of
Evgeny maravene ski conducting Leningrad
Philharmonic Orchestra and it was
Symphony number four you had to start
and it will be first and second movement
then you stopped change the other side
and then third and fourth mobile
continued it was such a total shock and
such a brutal change in my life I
remember I couldn't believe something
happened to me so some people are ready
to hear the power of music
but maybe some of the people are not so
we don't have to force we don't have to
worry that not five billion or not even
six billion living today on the planet
all madly in love with classical music
it's not a problem maybe there are just
100 million it's a lot you just have to
remember this it's quite a lot so maybe
there are half a billion it's even more
so I'm not worried about the future of
classical music because talking about
Mozart or Tchaikovsky if you go through
this hundred or two hundred years in
case of motor home or then there will be
six billion maybe ten billion people
maybe more so I am not worried that's my
answer
we just have to do it well and there
will be new and new and new happy young
sometimes I'll be not surprised someone
comes to the concert hall and here's the
orchestra being forty or fifty years old
and that's the moment he's feels
something because in our lives change
sometimes we go through personal moments
of happiness but sometimes this tragedy
there is drama even this is possible
that being 50 years old you just
discover the power of music but it is
better you are 15 years old even ten
years old already start to feel
something it happened to me most
probably when I was 14 15 most probably
so it was early enough for me not to
lose all my chances to spend more time
with the music rather than other things
I had many choices to be honest I still
love soccer then I played soccer up even
said 7:00 in the morning who would go to
the stadium and start playing because
that was a habit we head every day I
have no matter what sun shining raining
soccer soccer it was love of my life
then but somehow being 15 years old a
it was playing piano and then later
conducting very difficult to understand
why conductor is needed so funny when
someone makes this I was just lucky
laughing right it we're coming to the
end of our the conversational part of
our of our morning but I wanted to ask
something about the way you get the
sound that you want from from an
orchestra
there's a wonderful DVD of a rehearsal
that maestro Gergiev did with the
Rotterdam Philharmonic of Prokofiev
Skippy ensuite and you get them at one
point to sound like dust and you say
don't play like this play and they do
which is a remarkable moment do you
always use imagery if you have a piece
that's not about something that is say
just a symphony how do you get them to
to do your bidding well in case of
Skippy and sweet apricot if it was easy
I am myself skip because I am a set Ian
machete is relatively small nation south
of Russia but interesting history so our
settings are hares
just given culture everyone knows famous
skipping gold collection truly amazing
just so many centuries ago
there were people who were able to
create miraculous art you just don't
believe it that it is miraculous and in
China and Egypt in Greece but skill
skill feom omadd's you know they were
moving on the horses it was north of
Africa it was entire Europe it was
Siberia back to north of Africa amazing
story now a settings are very small the
skinning suite of Prokofiev is a very
fascinating
example of how Prokofiev was thinking of
huge symphonic orchestra incredible
power maybe it was his answer to
Stravinsky's Rite of Spring maybe I
think but to take this story Allah and
lowly in a skiff in sweet and to make
fantastic by the score out of it was his
task and he succeeded but even jagganath
couldn't make it a hugely popular ballet
production so it leaves on concert stage
very successfully and in this film you
may most probably you see how I try to
make Orchestra Dutch Orchestra not Oct
an orchestral sound very wild sometimes
sound very mystical well I can't travel
myself twenty five centuries back is
difficult to do even for me I am a
traveler no I go to 40 countries a year
more or less and like Price Waterhouse
Cooper I feel very global myself I am
just three days ago I was in China just
three days ago then I went to Moscow
then I went to some Buddhist board then
I went to Helsinki when I arrived in New
York all of this in maybe twenty eight
hours it happens sometimes to us
sometimes so but traveling back only
your imagination so how you make
Orchestra sound different you have to be
excited yourself if you are not thrilled
with the composition how can you expect
musicians to be thrilled then how can
you expect audience to be thrilled no
chance so you have to be motivated and I
think Prokofiev motivates me at least
the last
forty years I would say clearly he is
one of most powerful friends and somehow
he challenges you if you think you will
conduct his music please do it you will
be challenged because it's quite a task
from this huge and glorious noise to
make a vivid story where you see
characters conductor has to know a lot
about the sound about the orchestra the
colors rhythmic power harmony melody
Beauty very important because it can
sound pretty impossible
skipping sweet but then if you do
something and musicians understand how
to behave then it's a miracle of
sonority and I think since we talked
about composers I think composers always
hope that they create something and they
believe that it's not for library but
it's for people for life performances
and we have to remember this and so at
some point you feel you are not only
slave of composer but you're also friend
of composer you just help his music to
to be heard in the best possible way if
there's no story though what what do you
what do you tell me then I will invent
this story I'm sorry to say it would be
my own secret how I do it why I do it
but I have to be motivated so faceless
faceless is not for me I cannot conduct
rhythm only written for me is also
character famous conductor Toscanini who
spent much time in New York he was maybe
the best one who could make a simple
rhythm a car
because rhythm sometimes is what is
written it's organization but when the
little child makes and then Falls
this is rhythm so rhythm when we speak
sometimes the rhythm is even but the
best speakers buy a masters of rhythm it
goes slow faster louder so it has a
contrast that means it's a living living
phenomenon living the rhythm is a very
powerful tool and we achieved a lot with
rhythm I think and if you are so charged
with the rhythmic energy so even if
there is no melody in the whole there is
electricity public fields magnetic it
just public is glued to this energy of
rhythm so one has to try at least I
think Toscanini was great his his attack
of rhythm and his ability to keep the
rhythm was so phenomenal that you you
you feel like your heart is changed
totally you feel like you're completely
charged with something it's it's more
powerful than no calorie what you say
calorie you know eat I think there is a
way of energy helping you in your life
some kind of different maybe healthier
energy so the way to create and sustain
a musical public is to put them in your
hands and you owe them any hands I can
think of in the world still many more my
final question is if you could think of
one work that you'd like to see added to
the music humanities curriculum what
would that be you know we never talked
about composers were half forgotten but
recently in London very recently ten
days ago maybe
Brazilian pianist Nelson fryer played an
encore
we played Brahms concerto number two
fantastic concerto great music it was a
good performance his fantastic pianist
and then you know once twice three four
times work and then Tornetta you should
play in core you think so because not
every time in London you are asked to
play in choral normally public wants to
just express how happy in the public is
so if it lasts more than 30 seconds it
means public is happy it lasted maybe
already three four minutes then I
thought what it's appropriate as it
Nasser can you play this encore you
remember played in Moscow it was
glueck not Mozart not ready not
Tchaikovsky not Wagner not Puccini
it was glueck it was you know just to be
in paradise for just two three minutes
yet another time I was convinced that
learn more you will always find another
miracle in a musical world they are
plenty and we think we know no we don't
there is much more than we know
and this encore made entire Barbican
Centre everyone's and fraud you know
this is it so beautiful it was and then
it was explosion or very quiet very
quiet no nothing really
bombastic not nothing too powerful but
the power of music and the beauty of
music is power so we have to learn and
my answer is that in this case it is
this piece of glue and core very short
but my answer is we will learn a lot
more than we think we have to learn then
the story of humankind will continue for
thousands of years and there will be
much more to learn for everyone as
including
thank you thank you so much we now will
turn to some questions and first the
format will be first we'll take a
question from a student from the st.
Petersburg State University one of the
oldest largest and most important
universities in Russia then we will take
a Columbia question and we will
alternate their microphones on either
side of the wood good morning ladies and
gentlemen I'm glad to greet our
colleagues from Columbia University and
they're speaking from the same Pacific
University and they have here students
of the Faculty of Arts
maestro Valery Gergiev is the head of
this tecnique and they have several
questions - Randy please the first
question is by ekaterina crystal
i'm katherine parezco I am student of
saint-petersburg state university now
and I'm going to continue my studies in
master's program there and history of
keyboard program and first of all
venereal Salvage all our students thank
you for one of the best modern concert
hall in Russia and for excellent organ
there and for opportunity to play this
organ and to participate in master
classes by such great organised as
Daniel killed and I'd like to ask you
it's a rich experience conductor this
brought a pattern and many
question is are there any pieces of
music but you have not conducted yet and
you'd like to conduct in the nearest
future thank you well first of all I'm
very happy to see you all around the
region second second thank you for
mentioning Concert Hall it was one of
the most important things I could
possibly achieve in my life together
with my colleagues and friends and I
think we did achieve a miraculous
results with a building new concert hall
for Mariinsky Theatre in st. Petersburg
which has one of the best acoustics
today available to anyone around the
world that's a big achievement and I'm
very proud of it
thank you for mentioning organ is a
fantastic instrument and I'm very happy
you have easy opportunities to come and
hear so many performances in this
concert hall and play this organ talking
about music which will be yet for me to
conduct and to learn as i pointed
already - I'm thinking of Pallas and
Melisandre this is a great opera of
Claude Debussy great French composer
whose music I conduct regularly and made
recordings of his music yet this opera I
will conduct for the first time this
will be most probably the most
challenging for me in the next few
months the premiere will be in March I
believe spring 2012 I will spend some
time working on this material it's a
fantastic music so I am very much
looking forward and I have to say if I'm
lucky and I live another
many years many will mean not just two
but at least twenty because two is more
than one that means already mania but
then of course I will do my best to help
a as many composers as possible be as
many young colleagues as possible
what I am saying young musicians young
colleagues young can be ten years old
young can be 20 years old like winner of
Tchaikovsky Competition this year the
new trifonov who is now coming to New
York to play with me fantastic gifted
very refined very mysterious I think
it's it will take some time before
everyone will say oh we know everything
about him it will take some time
he is capable of surprising us with the
repertoire with the qualities with
readings interpretations but I'm very
happy Tchaikovsky competition this year
was able to find some good young new
leaders most of them are twenty or
twenty something some of them are
eighteen or even seventeen Koreans South
Koreans very very good results fantastic
Belarusian cellist even got a fantastic
French cellist fantastic Armenian so you
see it's not Russia it's not us it is
not Germany famously known as a big
musical countries you know it's Armenia
builder Russia South Korea big country
big economy big nation but to win two
gold medals in Tchaikovsky Competition
both medals went to Korea it's a huge
fantastic result and huge surprise you
don't think normally this way you think
we'll
we'll be most probably we think of this
big school something so the world is
changing very rapidly and I think we
have to be with the young musicians now
I can easily allow myself to say this
that if I can do it every day I will do
it every day if I spot talented person
most probably I'll do something that he
is not losing 10 years maybe in 10 weeks
he will be already on stage play for the
public and then it's his chance if he
doesn't play well first and second and
third opportunity missed a lost then who
is blamed maybe he has to be playing
himself but he didn't really prepare but
we have to create opportunities for
young musicians and I think it will be
one of my most important tasks thank you
a question from someone at Columbia the
microphones are on the microphone it's a
pleasure I've attended your mala cycle
last year in Carnegie Hall of the
Mariinsky Orchestra it was wonderful
yeah I was at the end of the week I was
emotionally exhausted this is exactly
what I want to ask you in view of the
fact that you performed six symphonies
one night you had the first and the
fifth at the same time how do you manage
the intensity and the stress and yet
keep fresh with the orchestra in such a
project thank you for mentioning
motorcycle I don't think I will do it
regularly conducting two symphonies of
manner in one concept but one of my best
experiences on stage in the last 10
years at least was a concert in London
where I performed two symphonies of mala
at the Albert Hall you talk about six
and a half thousand people
easily attending this concert it was
televised by BBC television so you talk
maybe about millions of people and it
was truly very special why because it is
unusual to perform Symphony number four
make intermission and perform Symphony
number five I honestly expected some
people to go home after Symphony number
four because one hour is pretty much
what you expect from the concert one
hour is a little bit not enough but but
two symphonies of matter is very unusual
then we repeated the same program in
Salzburg for the Salzburg Festival and
again I thought in Salzburg definitely
in Salzburg many people will live
because it's the concert will be too
long but at least in London public is
famous for being able to stand for many
many hours to wait for the ticket and
then to stand at the Proms not to sit to
stand throughout the concept any concept
because this public is famous Salzburg
public is very famous for being black
tie
maybe average age is quite solid I
wouldn't say 70 maybe not 70 but
certainly not 20 certainly late everyone
seems to be interested in how this
program will even destroy the orchestra
conductor or will be certainly suffering
because you can't do two symphonies the
answer is yes you can in this country
you can say yes we can but I say in this
case in this case I will say yes you can
do it sometimes if you celebrate
composer but then you have to do in a
totally different way
you have to stress why number four is so
different to number five your string
have your string section has to be
totally different voice your brass will
be definitely totally different voice
your percussion your winds your
intensity the temperature of performance
the coloration but you spend 20 30 years
learn
I didn't have a chance to go and do it
but I think for us we are still mortals
you know it is not what you should do
throughout your life manifest like this
or Ring cycle in four days I did it
several times I don't think it's a ideal
way to demonstrate what your castel what
your singers can do so Wagner was wise
in thinking of building by Royal Theatre
and giving people one-hour intermission
between act winnette 301 aren't usually
made to enact one and them too so you
have to be prepared for a huge
experience with opera but then also
relief you know relaxation and I'm
learning still tower to relax during the
performance I mean I don't think
Orchestra should be always provoked by a
conductor to do something else I'm
learning right now even throughout this
check Oscar cycle how to make August a
feel both supercharged in the same time
very relaxed even with the most powerful
moments relaxation helps the sound is
very full but it never loses what you
call a beauty of human voice even if the
brass is playing yes they will play it a
big symphony - Simon is actually and you
want sound to be huge but you want
someone to be human you want sound to be
very full but still beautiful not hard
now it shouldn't make you feel like this
Oh enough you know it's too much you
know
so composers normally do not want to
tire the public so conductor also has to
learn how not to tire your public how
not to tire the orchestra and that's a
big art which has a lot to think about
has a lot to learn
and I am quite sure by the end of this
cycle here in New York
Orchestra will be still fresh because
it's not as challenging as two savannas
of mother together but that's what we
did and that's how we decided to make a
cycle work in New York and again I
remember one big outcome of this
experience for me was that Bhavan Avery
Fisher Hall and in Carnegie people were
not living in the intermission
so maybe public is in a way challenged
but happy to compare back-to-back two
very different symphonies especially
four and five especially four and five
are two different worlds you know and I
think mother was capable of doing both
very tender very dreamy and then very
full symphony number five sometimes can
be compared to maybe when the energy of
Sun starts to burn just you you see that
it's a nearly impossible to take it
anymore
but that's number five it it sounds
happy it sounds so fuller so electric
but it has this extra charge energy by
the final moment after that yet you know
it becomes nearly impossible but then
you are happy because you why we love
Italy most of us at least I think
because when you go and you see a
country which was built with many many
monuments of culture preserved many
really many but above all you go to Rome
and then is a fantastic weather and you
see all Romans 2,000 years ago built
this and this and this and all survived
even throughout this twenty centuries
and you you see how these people under
this huge South in the Sun energy built
such a miraculous city and this is more
or less what I can say about
certain compositions they come close to
impossible somewhat mother music is this
way some of Buckner's music is this way
but we love them thank you now we'll
turn to a question from st. Petersburg
State okay next question from st.
Pittsburgh please Alexandre Kapinos
hello I'm Alexandra kapinas faculty of
art music department valet and salad now
I'm working on a project devoted to the
management of the classical music events
in my native city one of the suburbs of
st. Petersburg named Sabrina what is
your opinion how can the young musician
help to increase the interest towards
musical culture in our country well I
was a very very shortly we will continue
to go to visit many different regions of
Russia this is our country Mariinsky
Orchestra not only place in st.
Petersburg or New York OS coxa played
recently very recently in a mosque in
Chelyabinsk
in Orenburg in Saratov in Smolensk and
so and so on so we always do it every
year
we visit another 10 reduce I think it's
a wonderful tradition it became so we
see many young people my answer is I am
not worried remembering a concert in
Smolensk where we had maybe 1200 people
I swear there were maybe 800 young
people something like that many yeah I
was in China one week ago we had three
concerts totally full of people maybe
60% of audience was really very young
audience you can see it but when you
make you bow and you come and greet
public you already see a lot of people
you see wonderful young faces that's all
what I want to worry about if they are
there it will be great
great for Russia great for China great
for us so I'm not worried it
we'll be great musical education in
Russia is one of the most appealing for
any musician and it is so hard to reach
it if I want to have a Russian professor
I have to go through a master class in a
major city or music school in mostly in
Europe or here and if I want to go to to
learn music in Russian and breathe all
that Russian culture I have have to
struggle with an incredibly difficult
application process not to mention the
visa application and one of the reasons
that I see in this audience here and on
the screen is that here I mean I must
finish nicely people from Russia and
here it's a mixed people also in the
orchestra's and in the schools it's the
same thing what can be done to improve
this openness I mean you of course
you're the best ambassador ever by fire
of fresh bringing the culture outside
but what about bringing us into Russia
to probably learn more well first of all
if you really want this to happen it
will happen it will happen to you if you
really want it second I believe
relationships between US and Russia will
improve I myself firmly believe in it
the government's finally will work on
the process to make it easier for you or
easier for our young people back there
what now always our since incredible it
should be much more natural to imagine
that but it took some time for Europe to
get this EU idea to be executed you know
and now you travel from one country to
other without this application which is
so painful sometimes correct by this
okay
I'm now more or less known around the
world I also go through these
applications I go to the embassy or
consulate myself so well we do it if I
want to perform here for you it most
probably will mean I will go
- the general consulate or embassy in
Moscow st. Petersburg and get my
American visa so in this case we are in
the same boat all of us but if we really
want to do it we will do it and I'm sure
the relationships will they're destined
to improve simply because no country not
us not Russia can afford truly hmm I
would say difficult relationships simply
cannot afford in the world as it is
today it is a must for our two countries
to get the better understanding and
better relationships music will help so
we will wait for your great orchestras
to come to us and Stan chica go Symphony
comes very soon you will hear hopefully
much more from Russian musicians from
russian opera opera companies in Anna
Bolena not only underneath trap code but
also ill dharamdas a curve and ekaterina
kopanova they make this golden trio of
this triumphant production at the Met
they all come from Russia and they're
all very very much related to the
Mariinsky totally so it was impossible
at some point for them to get visa Anna
Netrebko
went through this some 16 years ago she
was coming to San Francisco on my
request because I believed she will do
something very very well it was called
Ruslan and Ludmila I wanted her to make
a recording and to sing the production
and she had to come to San Francisco
where I was conducting and well it was
difficult also for her but now she is
the singer of the world but it was
difficult so I challenge you a little
bit yeah you have to be good get better
and better and maybe you go through this
procedure just go and get your visa then
you will be Russia and if you want my
help I promise you'll be there
one final question from st. Petersburg
okay so next question please
Victoria Durbin first yes hi my name is
dr. Lebon I the secondary students of
the Faculty of Arts to do - track can
you tell about your criteria of
professionalism in music repeat the
question please can you tell about your
coach area of professionalism in music
you have very good voice and I have very
bad ear it seems my criteria of
professional music is there is one line
which divides truly good or great music
and not so good not so great music if I
feel I am on this side of the line I
doubt I want to listen furthermore if I
feel I am on a safe side and I listen I
hear something what touches me makes me
feel a little bit happier you know and
makes me feel involved that means we're
dealing with real music you know we will
live in a world where you enter elevator
in the hotel there is a music play then
you go to the bar and a restaurant even
during the breakfast there is some music
then you down the street and naturally
this music coming to you from somewhere
so you are get getting used to some kind
of noise which surrounds your life and
sometimes it is I'm even scared to say
Gorsky or Mozart or Verdi but it's kind
of surrogate you know that way where
someone plays some music as a background
this is not what Verdi maybe wanted to
be played in every restaurant where the
forks and knives make much mono is that
his great music but that's his destiny
today it will happen million times in
st. Petersburg in New York in Rome in
Paris
so do you call it musical experience
maybe not that's why we built concert
halls that's why we we all hope that
there will be great acoustic that's why
we love and respect Carnegie Hall that's
why we came here to celebrate hundred 20
years of Porter
Elite Tchaikovsky himself crossing
Atlantic I didn't fly them 1891 the
power of music brought him here the
power of musical love for music brought
us here now to New York to celebrate
this unique and historical if you may
say bridge which our two countries built
long before we were born for me it's a
very important fact of us Russia
relationships if the wise people of New
York decided hundred 20 years ago
let's get Tchaikovsky greatest living
legend from Russia 1891 but the answer
what's the future of our relationships
the answer is it would be very very good
very smart very healthy it will prevail
I think because cultural bridge human
connection was found so long ago and by
so many people how many times shall get
us money enough played in Carnegie Hall
maybe someone knows the answer
Rock mining of who is in New Yorker
remaineth who is a great Russian he was
born not so far from st. Petersburg and
he spent his last decades of his life
here in America
he played nearly hundred times becoming
a ho he was one of the greatest for me
maybe the greatest pianist of all times
he also happened to be one of the
greatest composers of 20th century but
if these greats Tchaikovsky Rachmaninoff
Stravinsky should I continue you know
they found it possible for them divide
their life between Russia and America
and they remained very Russian being
Americans so then there is a future and
there is a hope and I very much believe
in this in the future and of course I
want to thank you are going to thank
Columbia University I want to thank
Price Waterhouse Cooper I want to thank
you all you all in st. Petersburg as
well for this wonderful opportunity to
talk about music and about power of
music and about learning from music so
thank you very much
I wish we had time for more questions I
know there are people still here but
we've had a rich in full really no no I
just wanted to thank you from I don't
want I don't want anyone to think we
came here to torture you really not
really not so if any questionable answer
with pleasure of course
hello my question is about pieces that
you found initially difficult as as
perspective as a listener my first
experience with classical music was my
dad's favorite record it was
Tchaikovsky's piano concerto won by Van
Cliburn was performing and I found the
the first couple of minutes are just
incredible it's gorgeous gorgeous melody
and then it I was only 10 at the time
and I couldn't make it much further in
the piece I would stop listening to it
and for a while I kept coming back and
listening a little bit more and then
finally I got to the whole thing and I
could see but initially it's there is it
is presented a little bit of difficulty
for me being so young to listen for so
long and and to it proved to be a
difficult piece to listen to I wonder if
I could ask you if there was a piece of
music that initially your response was
not so favorable but only after many
listens that you you finally come to
appreciate its beauty if you listen to
Tchaikovsky concerto number one
initially and it doesn't make you feel
excited or happy well then don't listen
to Schaumburg concerto or or even much
beloved of Bartok you know or just don't
do it
stay with Tchaikovsky maybe there should
be a second time if second time didn't
work then I have to tell you there are
many wonderful things
which you may find most precious to be
Dutch with and maybe it's not classical
music but Tchaikovsky Piano Concerto
number one is maybe the to say the most
obvious choice for those millions and
billions of people I just was talking
about them correct
and you want to get on the 11th of
October to Carnegie Hall and give it
another try
we will take care of it if you want and
this young pianist will make you feel
quite happy yeah he looks he's even
thinner than you are
he's quite faith but he makes quite
quite an impressive sonority work yep so
you may be coming here him okay what's
your name Steven good I think we do have
two questions
okay okay we have several questions from
saying to the books of if they have
enough time maybe it won't last
okay one last one last question about my
name is Regina I'm a student of faculty
of fat monster my question is about
karate minovsky and Alfred Schnitkey
operas or anime performed in Russia I'm
wondering is it possible to include for
example King Roger like with the Georgia
soldier in the Mariinsky future or
aperture thank you my my question will
be very general my answer question it's
it's over for questions correct but did
you hear
Kroger when we did it in some Petersburg
did you hear it Shimon off-key if you
did make it known
it was performed three years ago but
she's a ghost yes you don't okay if she
hurt my nose corporal Rogan performed
three years ago that's a good news
there'll be more of it we will work on
there on the task and contemporary all
20th century composers will get many
opportunities but don't miss they
Midsummer Night's Dream production you
have to see it it's a wonderful
production we just put it in July so
it's a Britain opera all the turn of the
screw is another brittle of us there is
many many great operas written in 20th
century including second half of 20th
century I think we will definitely work
on it and my answer is sometimes it is
more important that Mariinsky or the Met
La Scala instead of yet another
production of an eighteen or twenty otta
or teller one of my favorite operas just
simply putting on stage a contemporary
opera it's so incredibly important to do
it maybe box office sales will be
slightly less impressive it doesn't
matter we just have to do it and I
believe we all will do it and if you
think that was final question because I
feel very uncomfortable people want to
leave and then we will just keep them
here so well-well where we're going from
here is a reception to which everyone is
invited at faculty house thanks to the
kindness of PricewaterhouseCoopers so
please join us and ask continue to ask
the my strokes questions let me just
conclude by saying that it's abundantly
clear that maestro Valery Gergiev is
truly a world leader in the musical
vision that he brings to all of us
a fantastic addition to our world
leaders forum
he makes us attentive to the heartbeat
of the orchestra to its communal sound
to its individual voices and colors and
he makes the work of our core curriculum
visible and audible and we're very
grateful to him thank you